Flu season in the United States and Europe
is approaching.
Many people will roll up their sleeves for the jab.
Some will be protected.
Some will suffer.
Sure, the numbers are pretty good --
at best about 60 percent of people who get the shot
will dodge the flu,
at worst only 10 percent will be protected.
The flu virus constantly mutates,
which forces vaccine manufacturers
to reformulate it every year.
It takes about 7 months to make the vaccine
so different strains pop up by the time it is ready
which is the long standing explanation
of why the vaccine often fails.
But it’s more complicated than that.
And something can be done about it.
Why doesn’t the flu vaccine always work?
Eggs
The form of the virus used in the flu vaccine
is actually grown inside of chicken eggs.
Researchers discovered that mutations
in the virus occur during this growth--
often in regions important
to triggering immune responses--
and this can undermine the vaccine’s ability
to protect people.
Ferrets
Ferrets are the most popular
animal model for human influenza.
The traditional way to select a strain for the vaccine
involves injecting ferrets with an influenza virus
used to make a vaccine strain,
harvesting the antibodies,
and then mixing them with a virus
isolated from a human who recently had influenza.
If the antibodies don’t stop the virus,
the vaccine strain is changed.
Aside from the fact that ferrets aren’t humans,
antibodies aren’t viral sequences.
Ghosts of flus past
We repeatedly get flu vaccines
and are naturally exposed to the virus in the wild.
And it turns out that our first exposure in our lives
oddly sets the table for all flu reactions after.
This dizzyingly complex history
makes predicting the impact of a flu
vaccine in an individual staggeringly difficult.
OK, so what can we do about it?
Stop growing it in eggs
and start using genetically engineered viral proteins
Stop relying so heavily on ferrets
and more purposefully factor in viral sequence data
Learn more about the immune responses
linked to protection
and how to outwit the original exposure
Incorporate parts of the virus that rarely mutate,
ideally creating a “universal” shot
that targets all strains and lasts for a lifetime
But for now, experts say the flu vaccine,
even given its limits, can still save lives
and spare suffering for many people,
especially anyone with a compromised immune system
and the elderly.